welcome to google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud
today's topic what is high performance
computing
this video is divided into chapters
watch the full video or skip ahead to
any section of your choice
high performance computing or hpc is an
aggregation of computing power to solve
problems which are either too large for
standard computers
or would take too long it's also
referred to
as super computing for this reason it
enables the simulation or analysis
of huge volumes of data that will
otherwise not be possible with standard
computers
the common challenge with high
performance computing
is that you're producing or processing
more data than your infrastructure
resources can handle
and you have to wait for weeks or months
to see the results
which typically delays the innovation
and slows down research
you can think of a high performance
computing system as a group of computers
called cluster and each computer in a
cluster
is called a node each unit in the
cluster has an operating system
a processor with multiple cores storage
and networking capabilities for the
units to talk to each other
a small cluster for example can have 16
nodes with 64 cores
which is 4 cores per processor helping
you solve a problem
much faster a supercomputer is a much
larger variation of this
hpc job that would run across an
on-premises cluster for three months
could run across 125 000 cores in 16
hours in the cloud at little or no
incremental cost
and by augmenting your hpc environment
with google cloud
you gain economies of scale with access
to the largest compute and storage
hardware
global presence robust networking and
intelligent automated management
capabilities on the cleanest cloud
now how to build hpc environment on
google cloud
compute storage and networking are the
building blocks of high performance
computing
compute engine provides customizable
virtual machines running in google
cloud you can scale up and down as
needed and choose
from a range of machine types for your
workloads we recommend the compute
optimized c2 machines for most high
performance computing applications
but you can also select the general
purpose n1 n2 or n2d for
applications requiring larger memory
sizes or a2 instances
if you need to use gpus for very
specific requirements you can choose
custom machine types with the exact
number of pores and memory to match your
workload requirements
and get the best performance per dollar
you could also use cost-effective
preemptable vms which are short-lived
compute instances
suitable for batch jobs and fault
tolerant workloads
now the underlying storage system is
critical to the performance of many hpc
applications
you have a lot of storage options in
google cloud cloud storage
is a highly scalable object store to
store any amount of data
persistent disk is durable and high
performance block storage
for your vm instances file store high
scale is a high performance scale out
file system that makes it
easy to mount file shares on compute
engine vms
networking google's privately managed
global network infrastructure
ensures that your data and applications
are the least exposed to the public
internet
virtual private cloud vpc networks are
available to enable connectivity
from your compute engine vm instances
and configure
firewalls for your applications with
placement policies you can control the
placement of your vms
in our data centers compact placement
policy provides
low latency between nodes by placing
instances
close together within the same network
infrastructure
to speed communications between nodes
now
let's put it all together for your hpc
workload on google cloud
first determine the compute storage and
networking requirements for your hpc
code then create your hpc cluster using
compute engine instances connected to
the storage of your choice
additionally google cloud supports
several job schedulers making it easy
for you to start
auto scale virtual machines to meet job
requirements
or spin down a cluster when a job is
complete helping save
cost then visualize your result in
bigquery or ai platform for post
processing
from there just monitor the performance
and change the cluster
as needed security is important for any
hpc workload
google cloud's secure by design
infrastructure protects your data
applications and users with advanced
anti-malware
and threat detection high performance
computing drives research
development and innovation in many
industries from rendering the visual
effects in the latest blockbuster movie
to sequencing the human genome to cure
diseases
to risk analysis and financial services
or
even to design the next generation of
cars
if this has piqued your interest visit
cloud.google.com
hpc to learn more and get started
you